and an inguinal hernia is the
abnormal protrusion of
abdominal contents such as the
intestine through a weak area
of the groin muscles the protr
ding intestine resides in what is known as th
sac the diary in some cases herni
s that are not treated  cause
complications for example if part of
the intestines gets stuck in the hernial opening
the
blood supply can be interrupted leading
to necrosis of the intestinal tissue this
is called a strangulated hernia if a
surgeon thinks you are at risk
from this complication  will
likely recommend an elective hernia repair
traditional open inguinal hernia repair
requires a single, relatively
large incision newer laparoscopic techniques
require only a small
keyhole incision or
puncture which generally results in a
shorter recovery period by
arrive at the hospital to undergo the
c  surgery an IV will be
placed and you may be
given sedatives to help you
relax
laparoscopic inguinal hernia repairs are
done under general anesthesia
so you will be asleep for the duration of
the operation a breathing tube will be temporarily inserted
through your mouth and down your
throat to help you breathe
during the operation
you may also have a catheter placed in your bladder
to drain urine these devices
will be removed at the end of the
procedure a
laparoscopic inguinal hernia repair
usually uncomplicated  takes
between 30 and 60 minutes depending on your
situation and the experience of the surgeon
one of two types of laparoscopic techniques will be chosen
extra peritoneal laparoscopy or
trans abdominal pre peritoneal laparoscopy to
access the hernia the surgeon will use
cutting instruments called
trocars to create three small
holes or  ports in the
abdominal wall the location of these ports
will vary depending on the preferences
of the surgeon and the type of procedure
one of these ports is usually
done in the umbilical area
carbon dioxide will then be pumped
through the umbilical port to inflate
the abdomen  and thus be able to visualize the
content more easily next
the surgeon will insert the laparoscope
through the umbilical port the images
from the camera are projected on a monitor
located in the operating room
then the surgeon will pass various
instruments through the other
ports these instruments will be used
to separate the hernia sac
and place mesh over
the hernia hole this will prevent the
bowel from retracting through the hole
before removing the laparoscope the
surgeon will look at the area one last
time for bleeding or
other damage upon removal  laparoscope
a port valve is left in place
for a short time to release  All the
carbon dioxide will be removed from the abdomen
finally the
keyhole incisions are closed with stitches
or staples and covered with bandages
after surgery your
breathing tube and catheter will be removed and you will be
taken to the recovery area for
monitor if necessary
pain relievers will be given
when you can drink
fluids venous vision will be removed
most patients are discharged
3-5 hours after the procedure